nous avons décidé de suspendre tout
vols vers et depuis l'europe à partir de
à partir de 0 heures le samedi
a décidé de suspendre temporairement
classes à travers le pays dans tous
niveaux et modalités à partir d'aujourd'hui
jusqu'au 31 mars d'ici je fais un
appel au calme et à la tranquillité
des Boliviens, j'ai décidé de suspendre
jusqu'à un mois sur tous les vols
venant d'europe
et de Colombie
pour
ajouter aux processus préventifs
Au niveau internacional
ce décret suspend pour 30 jours le
vols depuis l'europe états-unis corée
sud du japon chine et iran
Il est important que nous comprenions que cela
l'isolement est préventif et
essentiel de réduire au maximum
propagation du virus
cette personne qui à la ferme dans le
l'isolement aura des responsabilités
pénalités
elle comme guide dans la datation mary qui est
ou plus granule d'aine au toucher à l'ancienne et
mariée et fred stein
Bonjour, je sais que lui et élève
rideaux envigado
tu ne me comprends plus je t'ai touché
aujourd'hui la mixité scolaire de l'école aragon
véhicule en 70 étrange comme c'est bien
qui le diminuent même quand c'est que le
art urbain paix jungles jupe et desséchée
de la prison
nous avons utilisé dans la question bronzage méditel
pavle partenaires de vente pour les infections
singles accueille les semaines de cours
l'état du bénin doit découler de leur
effectuer un spray hiver de bay sands
et des choses sauvages au bon moment
intello